[music]
>> Selection is very important. If
the person who's selecting selects the
wrong people with all my effort,
what happens? The selection of the right
people is very important.
And because of that, we had many
criteria, many requirements to do the
test this and that, and I kept on adding
criteria.
Which wasn't much for you. You had only
five types.
And we had the first training program,
and alhamdulillah, we found the results.
Then,
I thought, let's have a second phase.
The first phase, as I was mentioning
objectives, the first phase consisted
mainly about techniques, structure and
content,
knowledge of Islam, dawa to Christians
for 2 days, then dawa to Hindus for 1
day, dawa to other religions 1 day, and
15-day stretch.
Okay, now, what? Let us excel them in
handling question and answer session.
And while speaking, I realized that my
knowledge was very
shallow and is yet shallow.
That time it was shallow, now it is more
shallow.
Then we realized
that the unique point was the question
and answer session.
So, then we thought, okay, let's
train the people of how to quote the
references.
And then one day he told me, I'm going
to do the session. We won't discuss that
now.
The second session was more of
technique-based and less of information,
of knowledge, and more of practice.
Second phase was for
approximately 11 days.
Or it was for, I think,
13 days.
Then we thought, whoever does the first
phase,
out of that, we select the best who do
the second phase.
The first phase, there were about 25
people. Second phase, only 13, 14 we
selected.
Then we got requests for having
international dawa training.
In 1999,
we planned to have an international dawa
training program for the first time.
And we thought that people can't come
twice, so let's merge the first and the
second phase together. So, when we
merged,
it turned out to be a 25 days.
And we advertised we are going to have
this training program maybe about 8
months back.
And we finalized the list 6 months
before the program, well advanced.
And we did the program,
and we selected about
23 people. We wanted 20.
Finally, 20 landed.
Two or three had some
personal problem, they could not get
leave, whatever it is.
So, we realized that whatever we choose,
some may not turn up for various
reasons. 20 turned up.
Likewise the policy, as I mentioned,
it has been a track record for me that
whenever I do the training program, one
is at least kicked out, if not more than
one.
And in that program, one Malaysian was
sent back
on the second day.
Out of, I think, there were five
Malaysians that time, or four
Malaysians. One was sent back, and three
or four were remaining.
That time we had from 14 different
countries.
Alhamdulillah.
From Seychelles, from Bahrain, from
Saudi Arabia. And as I told you, all
these people are graduates and
Islamic University postgraduates.
And we found
that this training program, the impact
it had,
was phenomenal. Alhamdulillah.
And as was our target, masha Allah, 50%
yet
in the field of dawa,
giving talks in different parts of the
world. Some have joined our
organizations, some have started
organizations, some are inspiring
others, alhamdulillah.
What we are in touch, you can say about
50% are yet. Others, Allah alam, not in
touch.
And we wanted this to be secured.
So, at that time, we did the recording
with two cameras on Betacam.
Now, Betacam recording at that time was
top.
Very few people had Betacam cameras. And
when I went to USA, the Muslim
organization said, "Are you crazy buying
Betacam cameras? Israf."
We bought the best camera of that time.
Two camera job.
It was in a auditorium of 360 square
feet.
It was about 12 ft by 5 ft.
60 square feet was the stage.
60 square feet, only the next stage that
you have was our stage.
And we recorded on the best camera that
time. Two also was very difficult for
us. To have two cameras for 25 days
recording with all the material, the
cost was
We had to think 100 times whether to do
it or not to do it.
And we did it, and we got, masha Allah,
Allah blessed us
with results.
Before that, I took the training
program's notes of various
organizations.
And I thought I'll make the best
organization at my base.
So,
I personally did not
agree with all, so I left the notes, no
reference.
Then to get the experience, I went to
a public speaking course,
which was for about, I think,
7 days or 8 days, I don't remember
exactly.
I said, "Let's learn from these
non-Muslims, how do they train
the public?"
And I went to the best public speaking
course in
Mumbai, done by Christian.
And was very famous.
And the rules he told me of public
speaking, number one, when you give a
speech,
the speech should not be more than 20
minutes.
With question and answer session,
not more than half an hour. If you give
a speech of more than 20 minutes, either
you are fooling the audience, or the
audience is fooling you.
Either
you are fooling the audience,
or the audience is fooling you. And this
course I did in 1997 when I'd given a
few talks to
a few thousand people.
And when I heard the expert speaking,
I realized that we are breaking most of
the rules of public speaking.
Not all,
but many.
And when I asked my trainer,
when the class ends,
it was a short course,
only 2 hours.
2 hours for 8 days. It is not like ours.
2 hours, khalas.
When I told him that what you said, sir,
you know, this is
"4 hours?
Are you crazy?
No one will sit for 4 hours."
He told me, "Even if the best public
speaking skilled person gives a talk,
I'd given the talk on
women's rights in Islam with the
question and answer session. Went for
somewhere close to 4 hours. And what
he's saying is right.
He's not wrong.
See, many times you have to realize
that what the experts say is right, but
there's always an exception to the rule.
So, what he's saying is right for a
normal human being,
for a normal public speaker, when he
gives,
he cannot hold the audience
for more than 20 minutes.
He's right.
But there is exception to the rule. We
have Sheikh Deedat, masha Allah,
speaking in front of many people.
The largest gathering here in Mumbai was
2,000. The largest gathering at Preston
in the world was in Birmingham
for the debate where 12,000 people came.
We learned certain technical words. Then
we realized, okay, what these people are
talking about,
we are already doing it. Even Sheikh
Deedat is doing it, and I'm doing it.
We did not know it was called as XYZ,
which we'll discuss tomorrow.
Oh,
this is XYZ. Ah,
this is it. But I'm doing it.
Who taught us?
Sometimes experience teaches you.
Many a time with the help of Allah.
Not many a time, most of the time.
And we realized that many things what we
are doing are already there in the
training with
a word put to it.
So, personally,
I did not learn much
except for the terminology.
But I learned many things that what they
said is not possible,
we did it, and we made it possible
only with
Allah's help.
Surah Al Imran, chapter 3, verse 160. If
Allah helps you, none can overcome you.
If Allah forsakes you, who is there then
who can help you? So, let the believers
put their trust in Allah.
And even now,
just before this course, 2 weeks back, I
searched
for the organization at home with the
khali,
I'm busy, searched for the notes of the
best public speaking organizations in
the world.
Even there, I didn't
He said, "What do we do?"
And if you compare, it's not even 10%.
I give you names of for some of the top
organization. These are They're
world-famous.
And we speak about them later when we
come.
They're world-famous. Got awards, number
one speaker, this and that. We'll
discuss later on when time comes. I
said, "Let's give something new."
These notes
100% only from my experience majority.
Maybe a small percentage 1% I may have
picked up from
the top knowledge. Ah, this is what they
call as top knowledge. Oh, this they
call as gestures. Ah, this is eye-to-eye
contact.
Fine, it did help me
to formulate.
But then I started observing
Sheikh Didat's lecture.
Pros and cons. Started observing my
lecture.
What are the positive points or the
negative points?
And
the best
who can improve your speech
is you yourself.
If you know the techniques, if you know
the methodology,
if you know the techniques and
methodology, you are the best
who can
improve your own speech.
But you should know the technique. If
you don't know the technique,
you'll think khalas,
I'm king.
If you have that aura of being, you
know, I'm the best speaker,
khalas,
>> [snorts]
>> that's your downfall.
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]